Tom Curren joining us now to take a
victory lap good morning tom how are you
hey Dan how are you don't check three
laps well you did say to me a couple of
weeks ago when I text you
they said I think Tom's gonna stay and
you said you know I'll bet you anything
you want to bet oh good yeah so thank
you for reminding me yeah it's gonna be
a great spring we get outside all right
so what do you think transpired last
night between Robert Kraft and Tom Brady
I spoke to Kraft about 20 minutes ago of
Brady reached out and asked if Robert
had some time for him
Robert hoped that his Brookline home
they were going to sit down and have
some resolution to what was going on
even though negotiations hadn't even
really started the Patriots had not made
any kind of an offer Kraft hopes that
that would be the result of what was
going on that they would start to make
some headway and instead Brady was
steadfast and going over there to
explain that he was leaving the team so
Kraft said it was a very loving
discussion he's very sad I asked whether
or not I asked if he felt that the
Patriots had done enough in terms of
negotiating and trying to make an effort
to get ready to stay in Kraft said it
wasn't about that
this is something that Tom feels he
wants to do at this point and he wasn't
going to be happy in our system now by
system I don't think that means
offensive system I think that means
really the relationship at this point
well I don't think it's tense I don't
think it is disrespectful I don't think
it is loathsome I think that it be
understanding it's a philosophical
difference
Brady thinks he can still play at a very
high level for a while and wants to do
that wants to be surrounded by specific
set of players and Belichick doesn't
feel that way and they haven't felt that
way really since 2017 which is why he's
never gotten any of these extension said
he was old but do you think this is what
Bella cheque wants yeah in the end I
mean it's like
you know do you want surf or turf I can
take either you know I could take you
there Adam whatever cuz I stayed and I
had a source who told me this morning
and he said look I I would not be
surprised if the Patriots moved on from
Tom Brady but everybody wants to be
careful in how this is presented
presented to the media what do you make
of that
I think the Tom Brady and I wrote this
the other day one of the ability to jump
before he was pushed okay and that's
what he asked for with the the ability
to be a free agent he knew even if he
had signed a two-year contract last year
the ability for the Patriots to trade
him somewhere the ability for the
Patriots to cut him his cap savings all
those things remained in the offing yeah
I don't think the bill is gonna wake up
woke up this morning it said boy what
are we going to do now now he has a
massive amount of cap space available to
him that is not going to be gobbled up
by a quarterback and certainly to have
it gobbled up by a 43 year old
quarterback was not going to be
appetizing they're on their way
I asked you this last week I believe I
said what is Plan B and you did not
hesitate you said Jared Stidham do still
believe that Jared Stidham is going to
be the starting quarterback for the
Patriots in 2020 that's two different
questions and don't you give me that
don't you who is going to be the
starting quarterback in 2020
I think Jared Stidham has the inside
track did did you see I'm not answering
your question directly I'm going to give
you a different answer I think that
yards Didem is going to be given every
opportunity to win that job they will
make moves since the only other
quarterback on their roster right now
now is Cody Kessler and those moves
might be mid-tier veteran free agents
but I don't think they're going to get
in the Andy Dalton business I really
don't I'd be surprised if they did that
doesn't mean they won't but I would be
very surprised if they didn't say okay
let's let's just we can get done with
Jared Stidham virtually the same thing
we could get done with Jared it was a
Andy Dalton let's just ride through here
and see what we got
how can Brady be this buttoned up this
prepared to be the greatest quarterback
of all time and say I'm not gonna be
back with the Patriots but not know
where he's going
I find that absolutely I mean it's
unfathomable that Tom does not know
where he's going
do you believe that I believe he's
probably got a destination in mind but
this is to me Dan this is to me this is
a a 24-hour rebuke of what the Patriots
have done and why they put him here this
is hey I'll be telling you where I'm
gonna go but I'll damn well love to tell
you on March 17th where I'm not going to
go it's New England that's what this is
about to me I'm not coming back sorry
they had their chance they could have
negotiated with me from the end of this
football season until now they didn't do
it now the tampering period is under way
and they still haven't picked up the
phone last we knew we had a fleet of
tweets from field e8 saying that tom is
on the hook to make the first move here
we just need to know what you need so
that we can figure out what we're doing
I mean this to me is the Patriots backed
him into a corner and he said look I
just want you all to know I'm gonna go
someplace in the next couple days I'm
not sure where but if the amp Shermer is
not going to be back to the New England
yeah but you the game of musical chairs
here if the Chargers all of a sudden say
you know what we're gonna go all-in on
two Otunga bi-lo or Justin Herbert here
and make Tyrod Taylor our quarterback
and Tampa says we're gonna make a move
on Teddy Bridgewater here like Tom knows
when the music stops he's got a chair to
sit down on that's why he knows where
he's going I can't imagine that Tom
would go hey you know the best time to
look for a job is when you have a job
not when you're out of a job right I'm
sure that whatever conversations he had
on Monday
crystallized enough that whatever
opportunity has are not going to vanish
once he releases a statement on
Instagram you know he's not going to
have those jobs go away today so he
needed to have that security before he
made the statement so yeah I agree with
you on that but I do think that this was
a standalone day of saying goodbye to
the Patriots letting New England process
it
letting that happen and then he'll
declare who was supposed to go to play
for next if you could ask Bill Belichick
one question today that question would
be and he'll answer it
why didn't you sign him to two years and
fifty million dollars last year why
didn't you do this last August
why didn't get it done then I don't know
if he wanted to
I don't you did it but I I don't I I
mean you've been around him I go back to
I every time when somebody says man they
have to get along they have to like it
so their mutual respect when I asked
Brady at the Super Bowl when I did the
interview with him I said do you think
you and Bill will ever open up the
scrapbook and you know take a trip down
memory lane he goes no like like you got
it he laughed it was like you've got to
be crazy do you think we're ever gonna
do that so this is business for Bill and
I applaud Brady for realizing don't you
may have bruised feelings make it
business because if you sit here and
mope and feel bad and oh woe is me
and you know what you're gonna miss out
on the opportunity to treat it as
business just like Belichick does so
match him checkmate all right you want
to make it business I'll make it
business too and here you go bill good
luck exactly right how could Tommy ruin
st. Patty's Day in Boston
well it's bleak it's rainy it's
everybody's stuck in their house anyway
at least to give him some but part of
what we like to do is Irish is to crying
our beer I think today the beer your
your mug will never get empty because
the tears will just keep refilling it so
it's a it's a it's a bottomless mug that
you're gonna have today people have said
yeah there's this much sadness right now
keep your head up though all right man
I'm gonna write a damn column
Oh a damn column or a damn column CMD
Yemen oh okay all right well good luck
with that all right buddy
thank you Tom probably not talked to you
in a long time
okay it's awake Matagorda you had a good
run there you had a good run
I'm gonna go to the wake of our
relationship but yeah I'm gonna say nice
things about you all right thank you Tom
that's Tom II Curran